I basically do cluster has
an unfortunate single fail
point the NameNode.
The NameNode machine crashed or
became unreachable the metadata
about the blocks we lost.
But if you have a standby NameNode that
a synchronize with the active NameNode
the standby can take over.
This is called High Availability mode
and bar provides a wizard to lead you
through enabling high availability,
all right.
Now ,it is time to configure
high availability.
Go to Services > HDFS > Summary.
Click on the Service Actions menu
then choose Enable NameNode HA.
Name is guy anything you want.
Those are in my cluster.
So here, you can choose which host you
want to be running, the JournalNode,
NameNode and whatnot.
I have this set up as a DataNode, and
we've these guys are only running one
service each, so I put them here.
So now we have three hosts not
remaster services that mean
those are the DataNodes.
Now the wizard will lead
you through the process.
It's pretty simple, but a few times,
it'll prompt you to log into
the NameNodes with their
internal host names.
However, you'll need to
use the public host names,
since you are in the network
with your EC2 instances.
All right?
Now we see standby NameNode and
an active NameNode.
This cluster is now running in
the high availability mode.
If this NameNode dies,
this one can take over.